I'm sorry I called you I'm too excited about the shaking hospital I wonder if Dodaoto is sleeping
Thanks to you I can't sleep Because I did
n't get a prescription for medicine Or should I see a doctor at this time Even if I
go to a hospital in a Japanese movie  If I were a hairdresser, I'd draw out a long-term hairstyle vision, but if I
went to another hairdresser, I'd be ruined.
But it's not a lot, it's a hospital,
so I
decided to close the
hospital for a while despite the long length of time.
3. Uchino Hongo If the government finds out that I'm drunk,
I'll be the victim and I'll be the
one to think about.
It's not to protect the enzyme,
no one knows that Mr. Gar is the culprit.
After the ride, I saw Mizo and Shira-san together in the back alley at night.
Well, it's nighttime and there are a lot of people with
ugly backs.
with you